hey guys it's Charlie so this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 3
video had a couple special guest
appearances just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet the
episode was actually probably most fun
for you you know one if you really liked
seeing citizens steal like just seeing
people get their powers cuz that's
really cool but if you're a big film
nerd especially a big samurai film nerd
then you probably picked up on a lot of
the Kurosawa references they basically
like a lot of the plot drew from one
turtles in time because the woman's
father who was supposed to marry the
Shogun he was actually the actor who
played the Shogun in Turtles three
turtles in time if you remember that
movie it's a bit of a deep cut somewhere
Stephen Amell is like sitting and
weeping that they didn't invite him to
come play for like another Ninja Turtles
episode but the only big Kurosawa films
that I detected were red beard Yojimbo
Seven Samurai and a little bit of hidden
fortress so I mean there were Star Wars
references too so let's just do top 10
WTF and I'll do like all the Easter eggs
as I go along
number 10 vixen is a ninja on the ship
taking down everyone swiftly because she
thinks that they took down our man
that's gonna be her big arc this season
getting justice for our man possibly
trying to save him
so number 9 you know follow up on the
heatwave moment because their first
runnin was amazing they had this nice
through line through the episode we're
not you know number 9 heatwave is a huge
ninja movie fan the only thing I know is
that ninjas like to hide in trees and
they actually did a callback to that
later in the episode where he's fighting
the ninjas and there's one in the
background running through the trees and
they're not necessarily teasing
chemistry between them or anything like
heatwave and vixen but she does give him
the throwing star at the end of the
episode so just the look on his face
though it's just like Christmas for him
he's like a little boy like oh my god I
got the thing that I asked Santa Claus
for but number 8 citizen steel activates
his powers the way they're explaining it
on the TV show is pretty close to the
comics but obviously you can kind of see
the way it looks it's just like a single
color the whole episode was mostly told
from his perspective it was his big call
to action like he couldn't defeat the
Shogun until he got super zen about it
so it's not like he's super pro now but
I think he'll be a little bit better
with the way he's able to turn his
powers on
but as you can see it gives him enhanced
strength he can absorb kinetic damage
and he can absorb energy to a certain
degree they might test that later this
season like over in the Marvel verse
there's a really good example of during
Secret Wars where Thanos you know one of
the most powerful people in the Marvel
Universe goes up against Doctor Doom
wielding the powers of the beyonders so
you're like wow the unstoppable force
meets the immovable object who's more
powerful in Doctor Doom like rips his
spine out of him so like no matter how
powerful you seem there is always a
limit to your power so now you're
wondering does that mean that the
reverse flash could faze his hand
through citizen steel or maybe because
it's organic metal maybe there's some
workaround so hopefully they'll test
that out like open up a tab in chrome
reverse-flash versus citizen steel we'll
see how that goes down but number 7 the
farmer and his daughter their last name
is Yamashiro he is this excellent weapon
Smith so what they're implying here is
that he is katanas ancestor in the blade
is the soul taker blade because katanas
last name is Yamashiro so that was like
the big week at that but number 6
Adams big call-to-action you don't need
a suit to be a hero the comedic timing
here is almost perfect I built it so
that an idiot could use it and then heat
wave just pipes up an idiot is using it
so even though there were some moments
during the episode that were a little on
the nose like the way they use that song
at the end time is on my side you know
like way too over-the-top on the nose
for me most of the episode the comedic
timing was totally on point so they're
doing a much better job with their
scripts this season number 5 I'll just
say like vixen throughout the entire
episode just being super vicious I like
this version of vixen better than I
liked the other version of vixen that we
saw during arrow season 4 not that she
was a bad actress I just I liked the
character arc that this vixen is on it
makes her that much more dangerous so
she is out for blood in the same way
that canary has a little bit of
bloodlust in her like I mean she doesn't
technically have blood lust anymore but
anyone who has been a part of the League
of Assassins has an edge to them
that most people don't have so it was
kind of funny listening to her talk to
Sarah about the fact that there are no
ninjas no secret societies of killing
people she walked right into that one
there's gonna be a little bit of that
with vixens character this season like a
little bit of comedy fish-out-of-water
because she's from the 1940s and a lot
of the stuff that the legends talk about
is like modern pop culture references
who is this master Yoda that you speak
up number four that was actually pretty
funny they kept going back to the Yoda
well Yoda is like a pretty easy mark for
science fiction TV shows and comedies
especially but in the way that they were
referencing Star Wars Star Wars was kind
of a ripoff of hidden fortress like
George Lucas was a huge Kurosawa fan so
hidden fortress to Kurosawa film to
Seven Samurai bunch of other Kurosawa
film references during the episode so
like normally when Cisco makes a joke
about Star Wars it's really just the
writers of the episode making a joke
about Star Wars but in this case it was
kind of a meta thing because Star Wars
in and of itself is a ripoff of a really
famous samurai film which it itself is
actually a ripoff of Shakespeare if
you're not a big Kurosawa fan you know
just a famous Japanese director who did
a lot of really famous samurai films but
those films were actually adaptations of
Shakespeare plays so George Lucas
ripping off Kurosawa Kurosawa ripping
off Shakespeare for number three Citizen
Steel has this big moment he takes down
the Shogun blows up the atom armor in
sidenote it seems like they're using
this as an opportunity to redesign the
atom suit for the TV show and make it
look way cooler so I saw a couple of you
asking on Twitter whether or not Adam
needs an actual suit in the comics to go
small he does need technology and there
have been times when he's worn a suit
like an actual suit but it's not like an
Iron Man style suit like the one on the
TV show so what they might do is
obviously make a cooler looking suit but
also make it smaller more modular so
just expect something by the mid-season
finale that looks way cooler because
they have that super advanced ship like
they're from the future but rip hunter
is from the distant future he has way
more advanced tech so Adam will probably
have no trouble in
something really cool to build himself a
new suit number two was vixen joining
the team formerly like you see her in
her civilian clothes if you didn't know
she's a main cast member of this season
I feel like they did a good job of
cycling the team membership like you
have citizen steel and vixen joining the
team you get rid of the Hawks and you
kind of get rid of rip hunter so the
energy just feels a little more balanced
like they were able to retune the show
in that way and I feel like it was a
good job but rip hunter is coming back
being which as you probably guess the
number one the berry message in the
secret room with all the weapons I can't
allow my friends to get hurt anymore so
it's a very old version of berry much
further past the flash newspaper that we
always saw in that first season remember
that was like the you know flash
disappears in crisis so the time that
this message is from is from way beyond
that so for those of you asking what he
actually said like what the message was
you're not supposed to know they cut it
off on purpose so that they can reveal
it at a future time it's probably some
measure of last resort as in you know
Barry does the thing that he vowed not
to do you know mess with the timeline
maybe it has something to do with the
four night crossover with the dominators
but it's probably specific to what's
happening on legends of tomorrow and it
might be the reason why rip hunter
disappeared himself from what's been
happening so far I think he's operating
from behind the scenes so that he can
defeat the Legion of Doom and it has
something to do with Barry's message so
let me know in the comments what do you
think the Flash's message was but it was
a pretty good episode I feel like
they're still trying to find the
citizens Steele character like the actor
is still kind of working the kinks out
he's a little overeager but I kind of
get where they're coming from like he's
a little kid
he's been kept inside his whole life so
now he gets to have fun so I'll say
congratulations to this week's DC
giveaway winner Steven Thomas you win a
$20 Amazon gift card there is a new
round that starts now there'll be some
more DC this weekend but tomorrow I'll
be posting a couple Marvel videos
there's a Doctor Strange Avengers video
there's a Captain America Civil War draw
you know behind-the-scenes drama video
that I'm going to post there's this
really cool story about how Marvel
Studios had this internal war that
eventually led to Kevin Feige
the studio itself separating from Marvel
and going off on its own so I'll be
telling that story tomorrow well you
guys wait for that to post you can click
up top for like a huge behind the scenes
thor ragnarok video i just posted and
you can click down here for next week's
flash trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight